hello everyone and welcome to another
very interesting game from the 1953 uh
zurich tournament it's samuel roshewski
vs issac bolaslovsky uh you know uh both
of them uh rashevsky has been featured
many times on this channel abolislavsky
ukrainian grandmaster and a very strong
player of that era
it's a it's a fun game but it has a very
very unfortunate ending um to the game
so you guys will see what i mean by this
and also i've decided to make a nice
positive video moment from this so let's
check it out and then we're going to
discuss a little bit but not a lot as i
am planning to cover this tournament in
its entirety at some point so here
rishevski opens with d4 we have knight
to f6 uh c for g6 g3
and now bishop to g7 the king's indian
defense is on the border we have bishop
to g2 castles and now knight to c3 we
have d6 and now knight to f3 so they're
very very standard stuff and nothing out
of the ordinary here c5
attacking the center and the d5
white now grabs more space in the center
and now knight to a6 you want to bring
this knight to c7 and then you will have
additional support for b5 probably
knight 7 a6
uh here we have castles by white and
knight to c7 and now uh nowadays e4 or
maybe a4 are more popular options in
those days knights to d2 was uh
was the go-to move we have rooked a b8
now preparing b5 and white of course
prevents this by playing a4 with e6 now
uh black challenges white's strong
central setup and now d captures an e6
with bishop captures on e6 and now
knight d captures on e4 uh returning
this knight into the game with some very
nice pressure here you're attacking the
d6 spawn so obviously black has to react
to this so knight captures an e4 we have
knight captures and now uh well you
could grab the c for pawn and then white
will grab the d6 pawn and this is
exactly what volislavsky goes for we
have bishop captures and c4 but now not
capturing the pawn right away first
bishop the g5 we have to
continue developing
and interestingly you can play f6 here
and there are two games in the database
where this was played uh but uh it's not
all that impressive we're just gonna
play a bishop f4 attack this pawn now
three times and there's no way to defend
it if you play d5 we're gonna capture on
c5 and now well you had to give back the
pawn knight away but you've also
weakened the king's position a little
bit
so instead after uh bishop to g5 we have
queen to d7 by voloslavsky
and it is now as of move 14 that we have
a completely new game or rather this
position has never repeated again so
queen captures on d6 we have a queen
trait here captures captures and now
bishop captures an e2 attacking the rook
on f1 rook after e1 and now bishop back
to d3 and now we have bishop to e7 of
course this had to be played the knight
controls uh c8 and d8 and now the bishop
controls d8 and f8 and uh white will be
able to win the rook on f8 so here we
have bishop captures on b2 first black
will win some pawns uh
for the price of that exchange we have
rook to a2 bishop back to g7 and now not
going for the rook right away first
bishop to f1 because
well black still has the bishop fair
controls these very important squares uh
once the pawn starts marching forward
it's going to be very hard to stop it so
here first bishop to f1 uh bola slovsky
trades we have captures captures and now
knight the d5 attacks the bishop and
says all right capture that rook and f8
so uh
does we have captures captures with the
bishop and now we have rook eight to e2
and this is a beautiful movie because
your knight is hanging andershevsky
could just move at night the knight to
e4 knight to c for knight wherever but
he goes rook to
rook 2 to e2 and now says all right you
capture you capture my knight but then
i'm gonna win your knight or bishop uh
and there really isn't a better move so
here bolslovsky captures it and now
arashevsky brings the rogue back rook to
d2 attacking the knight and now if the
knight moves the bishop will fall now
it's a little bit uh
strange that uh
well white decided to do it like this
instead of just playing knight to c4 or
e4 because here black could even grab
another pawn with something like
captures captures and knight to f6 and
now it's six pawns against three and
maybe it's not so easy for white to
to do something about this also you
control the very important d7 square so
it's not going to be easy for black to
double rooks on the seventh rank uh
definitely
something to to be considered but okay
here bishop to f8 was played i guess he
wanted to keep the bishop and give up a
knight although uh the knight would have
been a bit of a better defender here so
rook captures on d5 and now c4 starting
to advance the past pawn we have rook to
e4 going after the pawn
uh and now not defending it with uh rook
to see it because we can just attack it
again and if you advance the pawn just
rook c4 and you will win that pawn so
you can't really defend it so you better
create another pass pawn with a6 now
preparing b5 rook captures on c for b5
captures captures and now rook to c7 so
now black has the uh past b pawn but
it's going to be very easy for white to
double rooks on the seventh rank uh and
do some damage here whereas if black had
the knight then maybe it wouldn't be so
easy so here b4 and rook d to d7 and now
rook to b7 is also uh
being threatened this will disconnect
the rook's defense of the b4 pawn and
you will win the pawn so here uh
boslavsky has to try something he plays
rook to a8 with king g2 now getting the
king off of the back rank rook to a2
yeah and now rook captures on f7 we have
b3 black really doesn't have all that
much he has to continue pushing that
pass pawn and rook to b7 now and it
really seems like black has nothing to
do here we have bishop to c5 uh at least
the rook is now on f7 so you don't have
to worry about a checkmate and we are
kind of threatening that f2 pawn if the
rook moves from the
f7 square uh but now comes rook to f3
even though this is interesting you
could just play for example rook to g7
and now let's say here captures here you
could go back uh and you know try and
play it somehow like this but uh
reshevsky decides to play rook to f3 he
attacks the pawn here
and now what do you play well of course
pawn to b2 uh luckily the white king is
not on the back ranks we don't have
something like rook a1 check followed by
b1 promotion
now comes rook to d3 and now bishop back
to f8 so you don't have to worry about
getting checkmated or anything uh and
now black has to play rook to d8 or
there are many moves sorry white white
can play here
there are many moves white can play and
he should play some like rook to d8 but
he played rook d to d7 again uh and
while white's position still looks uh
quite formidable it's actually now a
dead draw so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this uh well
a tricky move that boloslavski can play
and not lose the game while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
trick and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is of course rook
to a7 uh that's the move that uh saves
the game even though it was not uh
played in the game boslovsky missed this
idea and in the end he just lost the
game
but uh
this uh this would have been an
incredible move because uh well of
course if rook captures an a7 we just
bring the queen into the game and now we
have a queen
and the bishop against two rooks it's
very unlikely that we are going to lose
this we might even win it but uh if both
plays both sides play correctly it's
it's just a draw the problem is after
rook d7 white could play something like
rook to f7 and it seems like okay now
black can't really continue can't
capture because just rook captures back
and the b pawn is guarded
but you can just play bishop to h6
or some other move uh and you don't
really care black can white can never
capture here you're still just gonna
promote the pawn
and there's nothing to be done here if
you play something like rook to e7
trying to get some sort of an attack
here we just repeat bishop to f8 and we
don't really care whatever you play we
can always just repeat and you uh there
is no way out of this position so it's a
really really tricky position that both
players
are just stuck moving their rook rook
and bishop in this case
uh but in the actual game after rook d
to d7 boslovsky played bishop the c5
probably with the idea of maybe
capturing and then promoting this with a
queen or maybe just making a move
because his position is hopeless or
rather he thought it was hopeless uh but
now just a rook to d8 to check bishop to
f8 here richevsky played rook d-type or
no he didn't go for the back rank he
played rook d to b8 and he was in this
position on move 38 that izaki resigned
in the game as there is nothing more to
be done here there was something that
could have been done five moves ago but
not not in this position now arashevsky
will just capture the pawn and that's it
of course it's completely winning end
game uh bolaslovsky knows this and here
he resigned the game uh so just another
another reminder and an example that
even in your own games when you have a
bad position uh always expect your
opponent to make uh a move that will
give you that one opportunity to save
the game i mean uh
rishevsky here is playing against
boloslavsky in a candidates tournament
that will decide the the the maybe the
outcome of the future world championship
so you know
there's a very very good chance it might
happen in your own games as well
uh so this was uh uh meant a lot uh for
for arreshevsky's he was able to get
third place or rather shared second
place with david bronstein the the
author of the amazing um
international tournament book of 1953
and of course as you guys already know
the tournament was won by vasilis
mislove uh who went on to challenge
world champion mikhail botwinik
so
that's the game hope you guys uh enjoyed
it always look for great opportunities
such as this one uh we can check it out
again rook to a7 amazing stuff i hope a
lot of you found this one uh i would
like to thank duras press global tennis
network uh jonathan maesta david harris
and robert stadleman for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day